[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
actor danny masterson skips a court
appearance but his attorneys are there
to argue on his behalf as he faces rape
charges
the family of lacey peterson is outraged
that
ex-husband scott peterson may get a new
trial
and a new york trial judge captured on
camera
in a tussle with police law and crime
daily covers court cases from coast to
[Music]
coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin charges
against that 70s show actor danny
masterson are moving forward in
california
masterson is accused of raping three
women in his home between 2001 and 2003.
the women came forward three years ago
but masterson was arrested just three
months ago
masterson is out on more than three
million dollars bond and has waived his
appearance in court his attorneys asked
the judge to dismiss the charges before
he entered a plea
they argued in what's called a demure
hearing that the allegations are too old
and can't be prosecuted
because they fall outside the legal
statute of limitations
this could create all sorts
of issues for for defendants
that can be tried with cases that where
someone comes forward
and then the prosecution is allowed to
just sit back
and wait any sort of number of years for
multiple victims to come forward
multiple alleged
complainants to come forward and wait to
file these cases 20 years down
the road these cases are so
old that they have outrun the statute of
limitations
which was whether you find it to be six
or ten years
would have expired at the latest at the
end of two 2013.
under 261.82 this case is no longer
able to go forward and this court just
does not have jurisdiction
so we would ask for this court to
sustain our demur and to dismiss the
case
prosecutors say the allegations against
the theory involving rather the three
women
are being charged under california's one
strike law which is why masterson is
facing
a possible sentence of up to life in
prison the judge agreed with them
it is uh there's no statute of
limitations that people can translate
under survey guidelines but there's no
five year six year ten year
statute is alleged and you have the
three victims
i believe their penal code section
799 subsection a there is no section
so therefore or motion based on
a lack of jurisdiction because of being
honest that beyond the statute
that is denied masterson's defense also
requested a hearing to question the
sufficiency
of the evidence in this case the judge
denied that request
zamora and some other language that you
use
at least in your initial tour that
lack of due diligence in the
investigation the witnesses have died
memories have faded exculpatory evidence
is lost
and therefore the defendant testing
presidents
then in your reply you say well wait a
minute i'm not
really making that argument yes um
so there is no just kind of general due
process
argument so i i would deny it on that
ground
but without prejudice obviously as you
pointed out a lot has to be done in this
case with regard to that
carriantholis is a reporter who's been
following this case kerry good to see
you here on law and crime daily what's
the scope of the accusations how deep
does this case go
there are three witnesses three alleged
victims that have come forward um and
the you know in each of those cases the
allegation is
rape sexual assault and um
the part of the demur that uh
masterson's attorneys were arguing for
was that the statute of limitations
for one single sexual assault is
uh i believe it's ten years or i believe
it's ten years
and but the one strike law
as you said does not you know there is
no statute of limitations for
a crime that carries a life sentence
and because masterson has been charged
with three rapes
if there are more than one if there's
more than one
rape alleged then there is no statute of
limitations for
multiple crime of multiple or multiple
rape charges so the defense so that's
why go ahead
yeah i was going to say the defense
certainly put that on the record that
explains how the prosecution's able to
get around the statute of limitations
now i want to ask about this too there
are some links to scientology
which are being reported but this
criminal case does not directly involve
that church
but of course we have other litigation
surrounding this defendant and that's
where the links come in to my
understanding correct
yes there's there's a civil
complaint there's a civil case that
involves four
alleged victims um and uh
and the church of scientology is one of
the named
uh defendants in that case um along with
a number of other
uh friends and and um uh
acquaintances of mr masterson um the
they're two of the victims in that case
have put their names on the case the
other two are
referred to as jane does in the criminal
complaint all three victims are jane
does
so a lot of litigation for you to track
in this case carrie i know you're going
to continue to follow it
thanks so much and um yeah you can you
can check out our coverage
at crimestory.com certainly will do
let's bring brian buckmeyer and terry
austin in now to discuss some of the
legal aspects of this so brian any hints
as to the broader defense strategy here
what should the defense be doing in your
opinion
i think right now the defense is doing
exactly what they should be and that's
focusing
on any legal arguments that might be
able to dismantle this case
the perfect one is a statue of
limitations the next step here is to get
as
much discovery as possible and try to do
further litigation to narrow the scope
of the evidence that could possibly be
presented to a jury and terry any sense
of what the prosecutors should be doing
now should they just be doing more of
the same because they're basically
winning
well they have to make sure that they
stay under the california's
one strike law meaning that they have to
have aggravated circumstances here
so none of the case is dropped so making
sure that they have either you know
young victims or multiple victims and
here they do have
multiple victims with a possible life
sentence so i think they'll be able to
survive
that challenge at this point in time so
brian when we listen to the defense
argument there
it ultimately didn't end with a win for
the defense on the statute of
limitations but the defense obviously
has to make the argument and we need to
point that out as well
absolutely i mean just think about it
this way yes are we all
disgusted by allegations of rape but if
rape allegations are
false do you not want an individual to
take every legal attempt to prove that
and you've got to err on the side of
that's a possibility especially if
you're a defense attorney
and stature limitations arguments even
if they don't necessarily go
anywhere you've got to at least put them
on the record as a defense attorney
you're not doing your job exactly it's
ineffective assistance of counsel
yeah then you're in trouble and uh it's
even bigger problem than uh just getting
a denial for an
argument so that's why we watch those go
by let's move on now because still ahead
here on law and crime daily singer phil
collins
takes a legal step to kick his ex-wife
out of his house
and later on we dig further into body
camera footage of george floyd being
arrested
a year before his fatal encounter with
the police
what's the defense trying to prove here
more on that when we return
[Music]
several other legal celebrities i should
say are facing legal trouble
pop legend phil collins takes his
ex-wife to court hoping to get her
kicked out of his 40
million mansion in miami beach collins
and his
ex-wife divorced 14 years ago but
collins claims they got back together
when
they were an item in 2015. ex-wife
married another man two months ago and
collins claims the new couple moved into
his place without permission and he's
even hired armed guards to patrol the
property
singer and drummer calls that move
outrageous
a former child star from the sitcom home
improvement spending time in jail over
the weekend on accusations he strangled
his girlfriend
police in eugene oregon went to 39 year
old zachary ty brian's house friday
night for a report of a dispute
officers said brian choked his
girlfriend and took her cell phone
but she refused medical treatment brian
was booked into the county jail where
that mug shot was taken
a judge is refusing to admit body camera
evidence of george floyd's unrelated
2019 arrest into evidence
in the upcoming trials of four officers
accused of murdering floyd
this year the 2019 video shows floyd
fighting with but ultimately complying
with police officers
the defense argued that the video proves
the police handled floyd properly
when he agreed to get into a squad car
because no one was hurt
in this 2019 encounter in this video
floyd admitted he was struggling with
addiction
and had taken as many as eight pills
here's more of the interaction
george listen to me listen to me
i need you to relax we are not going to
jail right now
okay
so i need you to relax okay
george relax
[Music]
making it bigger than it is
the video goes on to show officers
removing floyd's cuffs they ultimately
took him for treatment where his blood
pressure was dangerously high
the defense is accusing prosecutors are
presenting a so-called false narrative
of who george floyd really was
and they say this video proves more of
their side of the story
the defense for the four officers
accused of killing floyd
argued that this footage proves floyd
would be alive today
had he agreed to get into the squad car
during his arrest
which proved fatal this past summer
brian got to ask a legal question here
the judge allowed
the video to be made public that we just
watched and said it couldn't
be used as evidence now that makes sense
to me at least from an open record
standpoint released a video
it might make sense from a relevance
standard to not put it into evidence but
then the judge said a transcript of the
video
could be used at trial so why the
transcript but not the video we just
watched
i have no clue there are some times that
you have
judges who are going to try to for a
lack of a better term split the baby to
kind of make everyone happy make the
media happy
make the defense attorney happy make the
prosecutor happy but in doing so
don't really achieve anything i i don't
see how you can let the transcript in
but not the video that's bewildering
yeah it's strange to me terry does this
make any sense to you
like like the transcript is going to
somehow tell the jury more than the
video would
you know aaron i agree with brian here
it makes no
sense at all why let the transcript and
not the video and the other issue is the
judge is saying that the public can see
it
but if the public sees it then there is
the potential
that jurors might see it future jurors
might see it so
to me it's either all or nothing don't
let any of it in
or make sure that you know all of it
gets in
so this sort of splitting the baby isn't
going to solve the issue for the judge
as far as i'm concerned yeah we've got a
best evidence rule that would at least
in my interpretation suggest terry
that this gets in because then people
can watch it and read the transcript
that's right let it all in i agree with
the transparency it should get in and i
think it would help
frankly floyd's position or his family's
position
i mean there's a couple ways to argue
about what we see in that video but
apparently the decision is the jury gets
the transcript and not the video itself
well coming up after the break here on
law on crime daily a new york trial
judge and his wife caught on body camera
video
in a confrontation with police that you
won't want to miss and
family of murder victim lacey peterson
is not happy that her husband scott may
ultimately get
a new trial over her murder we're back
after this
[Music]
the family of murder victim lacey
peterson is reportedly disgusted a court
ordered a review of her hus
of lacey's husband's conviction husband
scott peterson was found guilty of
murdering lacey and their unborn child
conor on christmas eve 2002
but the state's highest court is now
telling a san mateo
county judge to determine if peterson
should get a new trial
the high court agreed a juror committed
prejudicial misconduct by
not disclosing she was a victim of a
crime
in her past a source close to lacey's
family told people magazine that the
family is stunned and that the court's
decision is a nightmare
peterson's death sentence was overturned
this summer in a separate appeal
peterson's trial attorney mark garagos
told law and crime daily recently that
peterson is innocent
what it means and if you play it out
there's no way they convict him
i i just don't believe that's going to
happen i mean people can talk about
he's guilty he's guilty he's guilty the
fact is nobody knew
knows or knew that evidence better than
our team did in real time
and there wasn't a single person on the
team who didn't feel as if
there was a complete collapse of any
evidence by the way
including the trial judge at various
times during this case
there is no to my mind justice that has
been for lacey
for scott for conor or for either of the
families
let's jump in for some discussion here
so terry we're in this area of legal
theory especially in the state of
california where victims rights are
paramount so does it
it surprised you though that lacie
peterson's family is expressing this
outrage because they have a lot of
constitutional provisions and other
legal authorities in california that
basically are on their side in this case
well that's right they do have some
victims rights and
one of those rights is restitution they
also have the right to be heard we've
heard all the victim impact statements
in other cases
but here they really can't do much first
the death sentence was overturned
now the court is going to re-examine the
conviction
and really it is up to the prosecution
they
have discretion to determine whether or
not
they're going to go forward so here the
victim's family really doesn't
have any rights as far as reviewing the
case is concerned
they're going to have to sit through
another trial if that's where we come
out here and sadly they're going to have
to listen to
all of that once again if that is in
fact what happens at the end of the day
yeah i mean victims have constitutional
rights in california but where they
go up against the rights of the
defendant oftentimes the defendant's
rights
prevail here in a case like this brian
the harsh reality is that oftentimes
move
moves defense attorneys like yourself
have to make will upset a victim's
family
yeah and unfortunately we as defense
attorneys have to compartmentalize
and we have to focus on the job at hand
and that's representing our client
as best as possible within the
guidelines of the law and
we can't really take into consideration
other people's feelings unfortunately
yeah i mean ultimately we hope justice
comes out of a case like this
was justice served the first time a lot
of people think that it was but it's
going to be up to the judge whether to
grant a new trial here
when we come back here on law and crime
daily a new york state trial
judge captured on police body camera
dropping the names of high-powered
supporters and relatives on the force
before he and his wife ultimately end up
in handcuffs
[Music]
a new york state supreme court judge is
facing criticism after body camera video
showed him threatening to use his
political and legal connections against
a group of buffalo police officers
who were trying to break up a
disturbance body camera video shows the
profanity-laden
encounter the police tried to put the
judge's wife in handcuffs
and in a squad car after she kept
screaming at officers trying to
interview neighbors
a man identified as the judge can be
heard saying the police shouldn't touch
his wife and
then threatening to use his friendship
with the mayor for instance
and other police officers who happen to
be relatives to deal with the matter
the man identified as the judge even
shoves the officers and they shove back
at one point
here's where things became heated we've
cut out the cussing
ma'am if you don't stop yelling this is
going to be a problem for you
okay cool then get over here
no you have no idea okay
okay push your hands behind your back
and we're gonna have a problem
put your hand behind your back
i don't care i don't care if it gets you
pieces of shit i'm so done listening to
you scream
why because it's the truth
no because i want everybody talk
okay so the video also shows the man
identified as the judge saying
he's calling who he identifies as
relatives on the police force he then
goes on
to explain the dispute started over
where his so-called troublemaker
neighbors parked their vehicles and he
also drops the name of the city's mayor
byron brown who he said was a friend
yeah i'm talking to my daughter as a
police officer okay okay
okay ashley moya dave paul
you have three police officers you want
to hear start a story
hi luke luciano i don't know you got you
you got officers mulligan i don't know
who these guys are but maria's in the
back of the car where does your daughter
work for
she didn't beat this word i saw that see
this one they can't wait to start
problems okay okay and listen i'm good
friends with brian brown
he's like you know what's up mark just
storm i did ignore him i called and said
the truck is
blocking half the driveway and then we
come back
that's how it does i'm talking like this
can punch me in the face i'm getting a
fair lit
i want to have my shirt wrapped like
this he
tore the shirt grabbing me and
ripped my necklace off okay okay like
like yeah like i'm i'm fighting the guy
okay there's a lot of that video there
later on the police put the man
identified as the judge who you just saw
there in handcuffs
and then there was another screaming
match that ensued so terry any guess as
to why no criminal charges were filed
against the judge in this case and
brian's already losing it so terry
please say your piece now
well i think the charges were not filed
because they are
well connected and this was sort of a
professional courtesy i mean
they said there were no charges filed
because
the judge didn't tackle anybody he
didn't really punch anybody he just sort
of gave a shove
but honestly it is because the judge and
his wife
have family who are you know authority
and they know a bunch of people and so
it was kind of like
wink-wink professional courtesy we're
not going to charge anything
against you okay brian so the new york
times is reporting that the judicial
conduct authorities in new york state
are
looking into this investigating is that
the only remedy here for this particular
situation well
part of me wants to ask that question
but but i got to back up here brian
sorry how many of your clients can shove
a cop and then not be charged
okay so assault of an officer uh
resisting arrest
potentially when you threaten a
governmental agent to stop doing their
job potentially
we're talking about d felony terroristic
threats
all of these are crimes punished by by
up to maybe like seven and a half
ten years all that he committed he's not
the right hue
to be arrested for those charges he's
too well connected to the rest of those
charges
and that's not a remedy because
nothing's going to happen it's going to
be investigated slap on the wrist he'll
be back on the bench by next year
brian i have a feeling that you're going
to continue to watch this video long
after the end of this broadcast thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime
is the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this
is law and crime
[Music]
so
[Music]
you